Okay.
In this video,
we'll look at an example of what we get
when we train an auto encoder on some
real data.
All right,
so we have this auto encoder here.
It's a feed forward neural network.
It outputs a reconstruction of the input
and then we've looked at how we could
define a loss that compares the
reconstruction with the input.
And then using that loss we can,
uh,
compute the gradients which respect
to the pre activation and then back
propagate that through the network in
order to do stochastic gradient descent
training of the auto encoder
on some set of unlabeled data.
So let's look at what we get in terms of,
uh,
a later and representation
in terms of features.
If we train such an auto
encoder, uh, on some real data.
So we'll go back to the
MDS data set, which, uh,
we've looked at the phone when we talked
about the restrictive Bolsa machine. So,
uh,
we'll train,
we'll a lot of show is a result of
training and ongoing color on that,
the same data. And, uh,
we'll look at each hidden unit in the
encoder and see what kind of features it
extracts, what kind of representation
it extracts from the input.
So again,
each square here is going to be one
hidden unit in a deal toy quarter and a,
it's a visualization of the weight factor
between all inputs and specific hidden
units.
And so gray means a weight of zero black,
a weight that's negative.
And why a weight that's positive that
we see that duo tone quarters seems to
have learned,
for instance,
that we tend to have either white pixels
close to each other in a spatially
localized region or black pixel.
It doesn't seem Harvard to have learned
a very interesting feature such as
stroke detectors or edge detectors.
Uh, it actually has a lot of them,
which are mainly zero and
they're actually kind of um,
uh, we'd say, uh, uh, they have,
they show high spacial frequency,
uh, but they don't seem to extract a
particular particularly appealing and
meaningful visual pattern.
Um,
it has understood that pixels around that
are in some neighborhoods tend to have
the same value,
but otherwise it does.
It doesn't seem to have understood
a lot of the structure that's got,
characterizes a Henry did characters.
So why is that?
And can we improve on that?
So it turns out this auto encoder can
still be useful in certain contexts,
and we'll be able to talk about this when
we talk about deep learning or we will
also be able to improve it.
And so in the next videos I'll talk
about what's a problem here that we have
with this particular way of
training on auto encoder.
And then we'll talk about
some alternative solutions.